tomorrow
[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor Hello friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact
they live in total darkness in oceans
thousands of feet deep where the water
pressure is Extreme
class sponges must be some of the
world's most bizarre multicellular
animals
these creatures have a lattice-like
layer of tissue surrounding a skeleton
made of a matrix of interweaving silica
spines silica that's right it's an
animal made of glass
scientists have found the unique lattice
structure of the glass sponge is
significantly stronger than any pattern
currently used by building engineers
one researcher said it's sort of the
Holy Grail of engineering design
Additionally the glass threads grown by
these sponges work like fiber optic
lines conducting and bending light
one of the most astonishing aspects of
the glass sponges is that while they
grow very slowly they don't appear to
age theoretically if not eaten by
starfish or destroyed by fishing nets
they're capable of living for thousands
of years
I tell you Pastor Ross when you look at
the intricacies and the design and the
engineering in the Symmetry that you see
in these animals these creatures then it
just it's more evidence that this could
never have happened by some biological
accident there clearly is an intelligent
brilliant genius designer behind what
you see in creation
that's right past it again it's not just
the amazing
um complexity of these various creatures
but just the beauty I mean we were
looking at some pictures of the glass
sponge uh just the perfect cemetery and
how they can reflect and uh transmit
light uh it's just amazing and of course
there's other creatures that they found
way deep in the ocean that actually have
these uh neon glowing whatever it is
bioluminescent yeah
you know there's even a verse in the
Bible that talks about this in Psalm 107
24 David here is talking about people
that go to Sea and he says they see the
works of the Lord and his wonders in the
Deep so not only on the land and in the
sky but in the Deep you can see the hand
of God and maybe our friends would like
to know more about that creator that has
that miraculous ability we have a book
it's called amazing wonders of creation
it's a free gift to anyone that is
watching all you need to do is call the
number 808
835-6747 you can ask for offer number
one one six we'll be happy to send it to
you you can also ask for this gift by
name it's called amazing wonders of
creation and then Pastor Doug we're
doing something a little different you
can also request the gift simply by
dialing on your cell phone pound 250 and
then you'd say Bible answers live it'll
prompt you you say Bible answers live
and you'll be able to receive the gift
that way as well just pound 250 or
800-835-6747 that's to receive the free
gift if you have a Bible question our
phone lines are now open the number here
to the studio is
800-463-7297 that's 800 God says
463-7297 well we have some folks lined
up but before we go to the phone as we
always do we like to start the program
with prayer
dear father we thank you for this
opportunity once again to be able to
open up your word and study the Bible
Lord your word is a light to our path it
reveals truth and Jesus said You shall
know the truth and the truth will set
you free we want to be set free in a
clear understanding of your word so
bless this program be with those who are
listening wherever they might be in
Jesus name amen amen our first caller
this evening we've got Anthony listening
in New York uh Anthony welcome to the
program
yes good evening pastors good evening my
uh I'm actually asking this question on
behalf of my wife um she was reading
first John chapter 5 16 and I think I
um when I spoke to the operator I stated
the question wrong
um it says uh if any man see his brother
sin a sin which is not unto death he
shall ask and he shall give him life for
them that sin not unto death there is a
sin not unto death I do not say that he
shall pray for it and then in verse 17
it says all unrighteousness is sin and
there is a sin not unto death so the the
question as I should have stated it is
what exactly is the sin not unto death
and that's what the assumption that all
sin leads to death based on what the
Bible says as well so
right well the penalty for sin is death
and uh so he's talking about interceding
here for some sin uh that cannot be
forgiven Jesus tells us really the only
sin that cannot be forgiven is the
unpardonable sin now I've heard some of
the scholars and theologians have gone
through the Ten Commandments and they
they say that well you know there was
according to Jewish law breaking some of
the Ten Commandments carried a death
penalty while you know stealing uh or
lying you might suffer the consequences
in court
but it wasn't the death penalty so I've
heard people uh try to approach that
verse that way and you see folks in the
Bible that interceded in behalf of
others that were guilty of sin and God
hears their prayer and and defends them
or delivers them but typically it's
thought to be the blasphemy against the
holy spirit is that sin
that cannot be forgiven and if you want
to add to that a little more any sin
that is unrepentant leads to death
that's right so the only way that sin
can be forgiven is we want to repent of
those sins
so if there is somebody that has sinned
and yet they have a repentant heart then
that's a sin that does not lead to death
that's right but if they have a hard
heart a rebellious heart they may in
danger of committing the unpardonable
sin or blasphemy against the Holy Spirit
does that make sense Anthony
yes it does I believe so thank you all
right well hey thanks so much for your
call tonight you know we do have a book
pass that is called can a saved man
choose to be lost and I think it talks
about the unpardonable sin in that book
the number to call for that again is
800-835-6747 we'll be happy to send it
to you if you're in the United States or
Canada if you're outside the U.S or
Canada you can always go to our website
just
amazingfacts.org click on the Free
Library and you'll be able to read it
there and then the new way that you can
request our gifts is dial pound 250 on
your cell phone and ask or mention the
name Bible answers live and you'll be
able to order the book that way Alex
quality we have is Philip listening in
Arkansas Phillip welcome to the program
foreign
might be muted Philip in Arkansas you're
on the air
yeah sorry I believe I was muted uh
thank you pastors for doing this show I
hope you guys are as blessed as we are
listening to
this every week oh it's a joy
uh just to clarify Anthony Anthony's
question real quick though why does it
say that we have to distinguish between
praying for someone that is sinning but
they have a repenting heart versus them
not having a reputant heart how I mean
how are we to make that decision
well I I think that uh sometimes you can
tell if a person is asking for Mercy or
they're turning to the Lord others
people they say I don't want God in my
life
and they they're turning from the Lord
you know the Bible says by the fruits
you shall know them uh that Jesus spoke
about the Pharisees he said or actually
John the Baptist said bring forth fruits
worthy of repentance in other words
Pharisees were unwilling to acknowledge
this and they were they were unwilling
to repent so we don't know the heart but
we can't tell by the actions by the
attitude if it is a genuine uh
repentance or a willingness for
repentance
so in some sense we do stop praying for
someone once they've reached that point
it says that we shouldn't pray for them
anymore
you know the Bible tells us not only is
there time where you might not be
praying for somebody
uh you've got places in the Bible where
David is praying that God will take
Vengeance on his enemies so I know
that's pretty severe we usually don't
preach sermons on that but it is in the
Psalms
yeah that's fascinating
um back to my question real quick in
Matthew 10 I had a question when Jesus
sends the 12 disciples out to the lost
sheep of the House of Israel he tells
them they're going to be going from town
to town why does he say in verse 23 that
you won't have gone through all the
towns until the son of man comes
well if you were to take that even
literally right now uh Israel is one of
the hardest places in the world to do
evangelism you are not allowed right now
to do public evangelism in Israel
we are on TV there I think just because
these a lot of TVs pick up satellite so
amazing facts is on TV in Israel and
many places in the Middle East but if
you do any proselytizing in Israel
they'll invite you to leave the country
or at least cease and desist so
certainly I think there's going to be a
Revival among the Jews before Jesus
comes I I hope and pray for that that
has not happened yet
and then also if you want to look at it
as in a symbolic sense there is a work
of evangelism there is a call for
repentance amongst those who profess to
be the followers of God you've got
spiritual Israel in the Bible you've got
literal Israel you've got spiritual
Israel there is a work of reformation
that needs to take place within the
church if you look at Christianity as a
whole today I think with all of the
various doctrines and teachings and
contradictions there is definitely a
work of preaching the truth of the word
of God even to those who profess to be
Christians and in Christian countries so
you've got the literal application of
Israel as past that I've mentioned but I
think you've also got the spiritual
application and if you look at the Three
Angels messages of the second Angel's
message says Babylon is Fallen he's
fallen we understand Babylon to be
representative of a religious system
claiming to be Christian and yet it has
fallen from the truths of God's word so
there is a call there is a preaching
even to professed Christians
yeah and some of the Apostles they write
their letters to the 12 tribes well
there were not 12 tribes at that time
and they may have been using it as a
spiritual symbolic application yeah all
right thanks for a call Philip good by
the way we do have a book called
spiritual Israel we do and send you a
free copy the number to call for that is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book
it's called spiritual Israel we'll send
it to anyone in North America actually
in in the United States and Canada we
were just reminded before the program
that they are parts of North America
that is not part of the U.S and Canada
so if you're in one of those two
countries we'll be happy to send it to
you for free otherwise visit the website
just
amazingfacts.org and again if you're in
the US you can just dial pound 250 and
you can get the book that way uh Lolita
is listening in Nevada Lolita welcome to
the program
hi thank you pastors
um my question has to do with Daniel 12
verse 12 it says blessed is he who Waits
and comes to the
1335 days
so I'm just wondering um what exactly is
that referring to
Pastor Ross you want to uh yeah we'll
give it a try
see if we can do it in a short time you
did a good job last time we've got three
time periods listed in in Daniel 12.
you've got the 12 60 the 1290 and then
the 1335. so the 1290s understood to be
the conversion of Clovis King of the
Franks that was the last of the various
Pagan tribes that was hindering the
supremacy of the papal power in Rome
that occurred in 605 605 80 Clovis
converts and eventually the Franks of
course become France and then the 30 35
if you start with that data 605 and you
go forward 13 35
1335 years you end on the date 1843 and
we find a great Revival that was taking
place especially an interest in Bible
prophecy around that time period 1843
and 1844. so the 1335 is being
identified as that time period from 605
to 1843.
I don't know if you wanted to add
anything to that it's you know the study
Daniel 12 is a tough question when
people ask us like when they ask about
the wheel within the wheel and Ezekiel
yes uh because you've got three time
periods and it's sort of a summary those
three time periods are summarizing
what's happened in all these previous
apocalyptic Visions again right sort of
a summary of the book yeah at least the
time period so you almost have to take
people back right and look at each of
them chapter seven chapter two chapter
nine to put it all together yeah well
hopefully that helps a little bit uh
Lolita next call that we have is Gem
listening in Indiana Jim welcome to the
program
gem in let's see Indiana they are
yeah good to talk to you again
thanks for calling
the question
that I have is in Zechariah Chapter six
it's about four chariots
okay
and what do they represent
um well one thing you'll notice is
you've got these chariots and it talks
about you've got a red one you've got a
black one you've got a white one and you
got a dappled one
um Zechariah is one of those books along
with revelation
that you read uh with along with I
should say Ezekiel and Daniel that you
read and understand better in Revelation
in Revelation you've probably heard of
The Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
there's a lot of similarity between this
prophecy here in Zechariah and the
prophecy in Revelation now four in the
Bible typically represents something
Universal in Revelation you've got the
Four Angels holding back the Four Winds
of strife so these four chariots are
talking about them going forth they're
really going forth everywhere and
who are the strong seeds typically
chariots were also used in battle
and so here it's I think talking about
uh you know the message of the Lord and
the the uh the progress of the Gospel
Through the Ages
now the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
is the first four
of the Seven Seals in Revelation you
read in Revelation it says you've got
Seven Seals and as they open the first
four seals they have four horses go
forth and you can't mistake the Identity
or that leads the connection between
Zechariah and Revelation where it talks
about the four horses the order is a
little different which is interesting
the first horse in Revelation is a white
horse representing the proclamation of
the Gospel the red horse is a time of
persecution a black horse is a time of
compromise with a number of pagan
practices came to the church the palace
represents the Dark Ages where there was
almost a death to the truth and the
plagues that came during that time
period so I think there is a connection
here between Zachariah and of course
there were judgments coming upon ancient
Israel more specifically from Babylon
and then of course he had other nations
after Babylon you got Persia and then
you've got Greece and then you've got
Rome so you also have four principal
Nations that came up against literal
Israel as well
all right so hopefully that helps a
little bit that is a deep study next
caller that we have is let's see Jimmy
is listening in Texas Jimmy welcome to
the program
yes sir thank you
yeah how can we help you tonight
yes sir I was trying to know what is the
will of the father is it in John chapter
6 verse 40 or in Psalm 40
verse 8.
well in Psalm 40 verse 8 it says is that
the one I love to do your will your law
is in my heart
yes sir I believe so
um well of course the law of God is the
will of God now what was the other verse
you gave us in John I've got it right
here it says John 6 40 and it says this
is the will of him who sent me that
everyone who sees the son believes in
him who has everlasting life and I will
raise him up at the last day
so you're wondering is the will of God
to uh keep his law or to believe in the
son is is that the question yes sir
that's my question okay
yeah well
believing in the son is believing in the
teachings of Jesus who said that his
teachings are to support the law
so believing in Christ means believing
in his teachings
he said why do you call me Lord Lord and
do not the things that I say this is
what Christ said and he said it's not
everyone that says Lord Lord that will
enter the kingdom but they that do the
will of my father
now it tells us in the Gospel of John
chapter 1 that all things that were made
were made by him meaning Jesus
uh that would include the Ten
Commandments given on Mount Sinai the
father did not somehow sneak away from
the sun when he gave the Ten
Commandments uh Jesus was part and
parcel of The Commandments being given
to humanity and so that's why Jesus said
not one jot or tittle shall on any wise
pass from the law so the law of God is a
perfect reflection of the will of God
and it's the it's the epitome of
believing in Christ Jesus said if you
love me keep my Commandments yeah so we
don't keep the Commandments to be saved
but if we love the Lord and we've
accepted him by faith we want to obey
him absolutely you know we do have a
study guide called written in stone it's
about the Ten Commandments but not only
does God want the law which was written
in stone but he wants the law in the
heart that's part of the New Covenant
experience we'll send that to anyone who
calls and asks the number is
800-835-6747 or you can dial pound 250
and ask for the study guide It's called
written Stone it's about the law of God
you'll be blessed by reading that thanks
for your call next Call of that we have
is Gilbert listening from America Samoa
Gilbert welcome to the program
thank you thank you for having me
my question is um I I grew up to uh I
grew up in in the faith in the FDA faith
and uh went to schools all my life and
when I graduated from
um from high school and joined the
military I got stopped going to church
and really uh just didn't
I I was just out of the faith I believed
in God that I was just out of the faith
now I was baptized when I was 12 years
old and I'm in my 50s now and now that
I've come back to the church I'm
wondering would it be right for me to be
baptized again
you know based on what you said I always
tell a person they really ought to talk
to a local Pastor to evaluate that but
just based on what you've told me if I
was your pastor and you basically had
wandered from the Lord for years and
been living out in the world you would
be exhibit a of a good reason to be
re-baptized recommitting your life to
Christ and get it and it's also your
testimony to others and sometimes when a
person is younger they could be sincere
at that point but I know there are many
younger people that might get baptized
just because their friends are doing it
and it's not really their decision not
that it's wrong to be baptized if you
you know 12 or 13 years of age but if
you have wanted away like you say pass a
Doug and you come back it's a great
testimony to your friends and family too
saying you know I'm I'm recommitted to
Christ does that help Gilbert
yes it does thank you very much yeah and
by the way we do have a book on baptism
is it really necessary the number to
call for that book is
800-835-6747 the book is called baptism
is it really necessary you can also dial
pound 250 and you can ask for the book
that way as well Elliot is listening
from California Elliot welcome to the
program
you pastors evening
so my question is regarding
um Jonah chapter 1 verse 7.
um
so it says and they said everyone to his
fellow come and let us cast lots that we
may know for whose causes evil is upon
us so they cast locks and Allah upon
Jonah so my question regarding that is
um
is it still applicable to this day to
cast lots
well I don't think God plans for us to
make important spiritual decisions by
Rolling dicer casting lots it is true in
the Bible when they divided the promised
land they wanted to find an equitable
reason to look like there was no bias in
how they divided the promised land
Joshua cast lots and when they picked a
replacement Apostle for Judas between
two candidates Peter Cass slots
these are pagans so of course what the
pagans did in the story of Jonah they're
not our example but the fact is that
they were trying they knew this was a
supernatural storm and they thought the
gods were angry and they wouldn't know
why what which one of us has done
something to anger the gods and well in
fact the Lord was upset with Jonah for
shirking his duty and running from the
word of God and so God allowed their
method of casting lots to identify him
and um
so but God doesn't recommend that we use
casting laws nowhere else in the New
Testament doesn't say well if you're not
sure what to do cast lots so
I think you actually a lot of flipping a
coin I think you wrote a book pass that
I'd call determining the will of God
yeah and you gave some principles some
biblical principles that we can follow
in wanting to know what God's will is
and again that that's free we'll send it
to anyone who calls and asks the book is
called determining the will of God
numbers
800-835-6747 ask for the book and we'll
be happy to send it to you next caller
that we have let's see April is in
Florida April welcome to the program
good evening Pastor Doug good evening
Pastor um Ross
um the Lord actually
um blessed me because your time and my
time in Florida is 10 o'clock after 10
o'clock here so I pray to God and to
keep me awake so I may call I actually
have two questions
um but I can't be selfish so I have a
question for not just myself but for
other people
um what is the difference between a
spiritual Jew and a Seventh-Day
Adventist I go to a seven-day Adventist
Church in Key West Florida and we have a
lady that is a spiritual Jew
um but when I asked one of the elders
what is he say he is he says he's a
Seventh-Day Adventist
so how do I determine what I am a
spiritual Jew or a Seventh-Day Adventist
all right you know it's interesting
because a lot of um my family my on my
mother's side is all Jewish and uh when
I became a Christian
my my grandparents said oh you know
you've become a goyam you've abandoned
the faith and then when I married Karen
he was a gentile girl
and he felt betrayed and I said look I'm
more Jewish than you are I said I still
keep The Seventh-Day Sabbath and I don't
eat unclean food and so some people have
seen that there's a parallel between
Seventh-Day Adventists and Judaism
are like they're basically Messianic
Christians so there are a lot of
Messianic Christians in the world there
that are evangelicals that are
non-denominational they're just Jews who
have become Believers in Jesus and many
of them have identified uh that the
seventh the Adventist Church you know
kind of fits in with a comfort zone but
there's a lot of spiritual Jews that are
out there anyone really who accepts
Jesus
and you're following you're walking in
the word and you're following the light
that God gives you you really become a
spiritual Jew because Paul says in um oh
it's in Galatians you might find it for
me he is not a Jew which is one
outwardly but he is a Jew which is one
inwardly
and Paul says I think in Galatians if
you are Christ then you are Abraham's
seed and again it tells us it's not
circumcision of the flesh but
circumcision of the heart
Romans chapter 2 verse 28 no that's one
of I think three or four verses that
Paul talks about spiritual Jews so yeah
every believer in Christ sort of becomes
adopted into by the way friends and the
most important verse on this is the New
Covenant we know the New Covenant says
I'll write my law in your hearts but
listen to the preamble says
after those days I will make a New
Covenant with the house of Israel and
the house of Judah he never makes that
New Covenant with gentiles so if
anyone's going to buy into the New
Covenant you become a spiritual Jew
because it's only made with a Jews and
if you look in the Book of Revelation
which talks about you know end time
events you only got two groups you've
got the Jews and you've got the Gentiles
the Gentiles symbolically represent the
unbelievers but Israel or the Jews in
the Book of Revelation represents the
Believers yeah I see a question coming
up here for probably the second half
about the 144 000 and but now there is a
third maybe doesn't Revelation also say
you get the synagogue of Satan yes
they're professing that they're
Believers but they're not they're
Unfaithful again it uses the Jewish
synagogue
maybe we'll mention it again if you've
missed it the number to call is
800-835-6747 the book is called
spiritual Israel and we'll be happy to
send that to anyone who calls and asks
again if you're in the United States or
Canada if you're outside the U.S just go
to the website amazingfacts.org and you
can dial pound 250 and you'll be able to
receive the book that way you know
Pastor Doug you did a program I think
it's available on YouTube where you and
a few other Jews Believers in Christ
spend some time talking about Judaism
and Christianity and the Bible it's just
a really great series of programs it's
called Uh is Jesus Kosher for Jews
absolutely so I think it's a great title
but uh yeah if you and you might want to
get a copy of that and share with any
Jewish friends you have to introduce
them to the Christian faith now Pastor
Ross we want to remind everybody that
not only is this a radio broadcast it's
been a radio broadcast for years but
we're also Aryan on TV now they can see
this on AF TV it's rebroadcast on Hope
Channel and soon to also be rebroadcast
on 3abn so be watching their schedules
be back in a minute with more Bible
questions
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
the U.S
message to drowning in debt to the tune
of 22 trillion dollars but before you
wag your finger at the government
spending the Federal Reserve says the
average American household carries over
a hundred and thirty seven thousand
dollars in debt while it was never God's
plan that we live with a burden of death
Proverbs 22 7 warns us the rich rules
over the poor and the borrower is
servant to the lender living with debt
is a stressful burden it actually hurts
your relationship with God in my new
pocketbook deliverance from debt I
outline the Bible principles on how to
properly manage your money with some
practical suggestions and how you can
get out and stay out of debt if you or
someone you love is drowning in debt
order a copy of Deliverance from debt
today it can be a lifesaver to keep you
from going under please call
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
[Music]
millions of people believe that planet
Earth is on the verge of some apocalypse
that will plunge the world's cities into
chaos in response thanking people
everywhere are wondering if it might be
a good time to locate their families
outside of the congested metropolitan
areas in my new book heading for the
hills a beginner's guide to Country
Living I do my best to provide a
Biblical balance I'd like to share with
you some of the crucial things you'll
need to know before you head up for the
Hills
I'd also like to identify some of the
Practical things you look for in buying
a piece of country land how to develop
water power and a garden all while still
seeking to save the lost this book has
some very valuable information for
anybody that's ever considering country
living what are your copy of heading for
the Hills call
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
did you know that Noah was present at
the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room but he was alive and
probably telling stories about his
floating Zoo
creation of the world to the last day of
events of Revelation biblehistory.com is
a free resource where you can explore
major Bible events and characters
enhance your knowledge of the Bible and
draw closer to God's word go deeper
visit biblehistory.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian Life call us now
at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends you are
listening to and perhaps watching Bible
answers live where we do our best to
answer Bible questions that are coming
in from all over the world matter of
fact Pastor Ross we just had a question
came in from American Samoa that's a
long way off it's probably uh the
morning there right now anyway if you
want to call in with your question it's
simply God says 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 you can also be listening
and sending in questions via YouTube
Facebook and some other social media
platforms my name is Doug Batchelor my
name is Jean Ross and we've got a number
of folks who are listening we got to go
back to Florida we've got Rick listening
in Florida
I can see what his question might be
about and I'm curious so Rick welcome to
the program
well thank you pastors for taking my
question how
insects chocolate covered ants snails
grasshopper burgers
yeah
well I I don't know you probably see her
eating the grasshopper than eating the
chocolate but uh you typically
technically in the Bible there are
certain insects that you were allowed to
eat and you know grasshoppers are
largely vegetarians
and so there was a provision that you
could eat locusts and it specifies
there's certain hopping insects that
were edible you not to be eating beetles
I don't think you're supposed to eat
ants or wasps or things like that and
certainly not a praying mantis or a
black widow but uh right or maybe a slug
that doesn't sound oh no I don't think
he grubs his legs either I think I think
it says that uh hopping insects six legs
yeah hopping in sick so
well didn't John the Baptist see Locust
yeah that word also could meet locust
bean and we're hoping that's what it
right but I just hate the picture of him
with Grasshopper legs and his teeth all
right thanks to a call Rick uh we're
gonna go back to who do we have next
we've got Henry listening in New York
Henry welcome to the program
uh when Jesus Christ comes back and
every woman who was pregnant
and she stayed but she hasn't been
without pain okay so when Jesus returns
will unborn babies be born I had a
pastor asked me this one times he said
what happens to pregnant women when
Jesus comes I said they're delivered in
more ways than one I'm sure that a a
woman who's pregnant that is a believer
that uh you know the Lord is somehow
gonna
help her to experience that child
whether right then in the uh coming to
the Lord when our bodies are transformed
Angel placed the baby in her arms or but
I'm sure it would be painless
and I hadn't thought you know maybe
when they get to heaven there'll be a
maternity word there are children in
heaven of course a lot of babies in the
resurrection how God is going to do that
that's one of the Mysteries I have
people ask me questions like you know
what's going to happen to those that are
in the International Space Station when
Jesus comes will they be forgotten or
left behind you know there's a lot of
the
um
uh you know
questions that sort of are uh
speculating who are in a nuclear
submarine under the ocean
I want to be there
so I hope that helps a little bit
there's no specific scriptures on that
Henry all we can do is speculate all
right thanks Nicole Robert is listening
Washington rabbit welcome to the program
casters hi
thanks for calling
um
you're welcome I was wondering
um I sometimes talk with people who
believe that Christ will have a 1 000
year Millennial reign
and they asked me well do you read the
whole Bible
um there was one passage that they
mentioned Zechariah 14
chapter 14 we don't need to read the
whole
chapter but one of the verses I guess
Verse 18 talks about
those who are there need to
um
to do the Feast of Tabernacle otherwise
they don't get any rain
um
um and that that seems to be
uh pertaining to the millennial reign
yeah well the Feast of Tabernacles was
basically a feast that coincided with
the uh Exodus they were supposed to
remember that while they were in the
wilderness that they were uh sojourners
they were pilgrims and so they would
during the Feast of Tabernacles they'd
make these little booths it was the old
Old Testament version of tents out of
the branches of trees and so forth to
shelter them from the Sun something like
the booth that Jonah made when he was
sitting on the mountain and those that
experience salvation
they're singing the song of Moses and
the lamb you know Miriam sang a song of
Deliverance when they came out of Egypt
so I Zechariah is going back and forth
in this chapter between a punishment
that was going to come on Israel he
talks about when the women are ravished
and the cities destroyed during the
Roman captivity Jesus connected what
happened to the Jews when the Romans
destroyed Jerusalem and signs of the
second coming Zechariah does the same
thing in chapter 14. this prophecy is
interwoven and it overlaps with the
Jewish history and spiritual Israel at
the second coming in the Millennium or
you know their time in the Kingdom yeah
so go ahead just after the capacity the
Feast of Tabernacles is a symbol or a
type of the 1000 Years where the
redeemed will be in the New Jerusalem in
heaven I remember the final home of the
redeemed is not heaven it's actually the
earth made news right Jesus said the
meek shall inherit the earth so the
Feast of Tabernacle symbolizes that time
when the righteous are in heaven well
then you read on in the same passage it
talks about those who do not come up to
the Feast of Tabernacles in other words
they're the ones that are not taken to
heaven when Jesus comes the second time
that would mean that the wicked
symbolized yah by Egypt it says they
received the plague well if you read a
little further you find out what that
plague is which is eventually Eternal
destruction at the end of the Thousand
Years there won't be any rain on the
earth during the Thousand Years the
wicked all destroyed with the brightness
of Christ coming so there's some dual
applications there as it refers to that
symbol of the of the Feast of
Tabernacles
so hope that helps a little thank you so
much next caller that we have is uh
Tanya listening from Missouri Tanya
welcome to the program
hi Tanya you're on the air
hello yes
you can hear me loud and clear
oh I'm sorry because I got kind of I
apologize yes um hi
um I have a question about the um 144
and also the close of probation okay can
you explain is the 144
literal and if it is what happens to
everybody else all right good good
question for friends listening the 144
000 is a special group that's identified
in Revelation both chapter 7 of
Revelation and chapter 14. and it says
that God has this group of twelve
thousand from the 12 tribes of Israel
and then it names the tribes and it's
giving them in an order that you
normally don't find
so one question is
are these literal Jews
and I believe not because when it's
talking about 12 000 from the tribe of
issachar and zebulun and Asher
those tribes cease to exist they were
conquered by Assyria they intermarried
their descendants kind of are have been
you know scattered around the world
Syria was later conquered conquered and
so finding literal descendants from the
ten tribes that were carried off to
Assyria it would be difficult to do long
before Jesus was born
but the reason it's saying that it's
talking about I think spiritual Israel
everyone who's adopted into God's family
becomes members of the tribe is it a
number are they the only ones saved no
you read later in chapter seven when
John is talking to the the angel he says
who are the ones who raid in white robes
that are without number a great
multitude said these are the ones who've
come out of Great Tribulation
and you find that in verse 14 and on
so through the influence of the hundred
and forty four thousand there's a great
Revival just like God had 12 Apostles
that were leaders in sharing the gospel
with the house of Israel in the
beginning
uh Jesus has got 12 times 12 000 that
share the gospel with the whole world
before his second coming
so they're like last day Apostles
they're not the only ones saved it's
interesting Pastor that you have literal
Israel that God raised up to prepare the
world for the first coming of Christ
we've got spiritual Israel yeah
symbolized you about 144 000 that are
preparing the world for the second
coming of Christ through the
proclamation of the Three Angels
messages that we find in Revelation
chapter 14. so very interesting
connection now I think Tanya was also
asking something about the close of
probation
so uh Tanya what was that about the
close of probation
well
can you explain it because I'm yeah
confused I get so many answers
sure
you know just before Jesus comes there
is a period of time when salvation the
door of Salvation is finally closed and
those who are saved are sealed uh
they're sealed with the name of God and
they're they're safe for good and they
can't be lost and and those who are lost
cannot be saved in revelation 22 Jesus
has let the just be just still let the
filthy be filthy still no changing teams
it's something like back in the days of
Noah when Noah and his family entered
the Ark and God shut the door the rain
hadn't started life went on outside the
ark but their Destiny was sealed and the
lost could no longer get in the ark and
Noah and his family were sealed inside
there's going to be a period of time we
don't know exactly how long before Jesus
comes when probation closes and no one
else can be saved or lost for that
matter and then after probation closes
you got seven last fall yeah and then
Jesus comes good point yeah all right
make school of the bath is Jason
listening in California Jason welcome to
the program
hi thank you for having me yeah
so uh before I ask any questions
um I'd like to say that I'm I'm a
married man
uh and my question is how do I maintain
a work and family life
by helping my parents and being married
and when my parents want me to uh put
them first before my marriage
um and I know Genesis 2 24 says you know
a man shall leave his wife or leave his
mother and his father and she'll leave
to his wife
so
how do I separate the two and then how
do I
yeah and still honor your parents
yeah I'm sorry and still honor your
parents in the process uh so how do you
balance those things that's a good
question
um when you're married and you start a
new family and you can see this all
through God's uh natural world there
comes a time where the uh parents they
usually chase the young away
but sometimes you know in the human
families we want to we want to keep our
sons and our daughters around which is
normal but it's important for the new
family unit to have some freedom and
Independence when it's established and
that's why God says a man shall leave
his father and mother and cleave unto
his wife and so your first Allegiance
would be to of course the Lord then your
wife because it says when you marry you
become one flesh with your wife
and uh but while at the same time you
want to do all you can to respect your
parents and I know right now there's a
lot of ears perking up around the
country listening to that because
there's a lot of families that kind of
struggle in the relationships between
the parent and the child and the the
wife or spouse of the child and just
balancing the time and the relationship
and the attention
it can be real Challenge and you know
sometimes young wives they think I can
never live up to my mother-in-law she's
always judging me because I'm not as
good as your mother or whatever that
argument's happened a lot so that's why
it's good sometimes to maintain a little
bit of separation and it's really
difficult unless you've got I've seen it
work in really special occasions living
under the same roof but uh unless
everyone's converted there's going to be
problems
all right well thank you next caller
that we have is uh let's see we've got
um
somebody calling from Illinois and I
can't say sorry to John John welcome to
the program
can you hear me loud and clear
uh uh good evening pastors uh we wanted
to give you guys a call for a while now
I just actually got your Revelations
verse by verse Daily Devotional oh
wonderful yeah I've been studying Daniel
and Revelations
um but my um
for a long time but my question is
concerning uh Revelation chapter 12 9 I
guess you could say through 13. uh-huh
um it says now when Satan was uh Satan
his angels were cast out of heaven right
um they weren't it says that they were
cast to the Earth and now just with my
studying and a little understanding and
you know even listening to some of your
programs when he was cast out he wasn't
actually cast to the Earth uh he was
kind of cast out and um and it's when it
says Rejoice oh heavens and
all those who dwell in them my
understanding and then it says woe to
the inhabitants of the earth and to the
Sea my understanding is that is there
was rejoicing in the heavens you know
um because God Jesus was on trial
uh in the universe so what I'm saying my
my question is for you guys kinda is
basically when he was cast out he wasn't
cast out directly to the Earth until
after
um Christ was resurrected and Rose after
the 40 days went back to Heaven all
right let me see yeah yeah let me jump
in because I think I think I understand
your question and and I want to see if I
can consolidate or capsule uh capitalize
that that's not the word I'm looking for
capsulate that
um
Revelation 12 is not something that
happened in a moment Revelation 12 is
covering a process of things the war in
heaven did not happen immediately it
started with Satan beginning a campaign
that may have lasted eons that finally
broke into open Rebellion he was cast
out
Satan went roaming through the universe
looking for a place to continue his
battle ultimately after this world was
created he found Adam and Eve would
listen to him and they disobeyed God at
the tree he then was restricted to this
earth
uh and um again I think his his access
to heaven was limited further after the
cross Christ said I saw Satan fall and
if you look at the verse it's
interesting you have him being cast out
of heaven and then it says I heard a
loud voice in heaven now salvation and
strength in the Kingdom of a God and the
power of His crisis come the accuser of
the Brethren has been cast down so it's
talking about the cross when it says now
salvation and strength has come so it's
as if Satan is cast out of heaven and
then he comes to the Earth and he sees
Adam and Eve but it was really at the
cross that everyone realized or saw the
true colors of the devil and he was cast
down meaning he can't represent the
Earth any longer remember the story of
Job he goes up and sort of claims to be
the representative of Earth now Jesus is
the representative of Earth and he's in
heaven representing the regime for us so
he is cast down then it says he knows he
has a short time so he is very angry
right and so yeah that's referring to
the cross and after that and the reason
that he says Heaven is rejoicing is
because he had been causing all kinds of
problems in heaven he's just not there
anymore that's right that's why he said
Rejoice Heavens he's not there anymore
well below the Earth and he's down there
going around like a roaring lion came
and wrecked the neighborhood all right
good question next Call of that we have
is Jonathan listening in Washington
Jonathan welcome to the program
hi good evening yes
uh just first wanted to say thank you
guys for your time and you guys always
have been really good uh sorts of
information
and I'm sure you guys know he helped a
lot of people
um I have a question about Colossians 2
14.
and
it says
in the handwriting of ordinances that
was used against us contrary to us
nailed to the cross and the word
ordinances in this verse in the Greek is
dogmasin and dogmasin is defined as
something held as an established opinion
so wouldn't this mean that the
ordinances nailed to the cross are the
tradition of the elders or Pharisee lost
and not the law of Moses
well if you look in the Old Testament it
talks about when the Ten Commandments
were given that God also gave Moses laws
and statutes that were placed in the
side of the ark that they might be a
witness against you Moses said they
might be there to witness against you
Paul is using that same language but
that's referring to the uh the
ordinances and these of course were
nailed to the cross meaning you know the
sacrifice of lambs and circumcision a
lot of the ceremonial laws Christians
are not obligated to keep that that was
fulfilled in Christ
so um
yeah the the laws that uh Paul is
referring to here are not speaking of
the Ten Commandment law it's talking
about other ceremonial or levitical laws
does that help um Jonathan
um well the thing is because it says
Dogma sin and it's only used twice in
the New Testament
um and based on the definition it seems
more like like if it's well it seemed
like it would fit
public opinion versus what would be
considered law
well the word dogma I think like you
said it's just teaching it's a pretty
broad definition I think the key is Paul
uses words like the handwriting
of ordinances now the word handwriting
is a key talks about those laws written
by the hand of Moses and then the Ten
Commandments written by the Finger of
God
now I think we've got a book called
feast days and sabbaths that talks about
Colossians chapter 2 and we could send
him a free copy of that goes into more
detail than we can in a few moments the
number to call is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book
it's called feast days and sabbaths and
it talks about Colossians 2. you can
also dial pound 250 and say the words
Bible answers live and you'll be able to
order the book online there as well
actually buy your phone by phone
thank you Jonathan we've got uh Linda
listening in North Carolina Linda
welcome to the program
I'm a revolution every week
um I'm just curious why does the bible
give two different versions on how Judas
died
one says he versed asunder and the other
one says he hung himself yes well
they're really the same uh it's just
that it's giving more of the story Peter
in Acts he talks about Judas falling
headlong he bursts asunder uh Judas uh
and then some of this is based on
tradition but the Bible says Judas went
out and hung himself we believe that he
put a rope around his neck and he hung
himself but he hung himself from one of
the scaffolds or something outside the
city wall and he wanted to make sure
that he could jump and drop and hang and
at some point the Rope broke and he fell
after he hung himself and tradition says
that it wasn't far from the road where
they brought Jesus out to execute him
and that he had fell and in the process
of falling hitting the Rocks below I
know it's not a pretty picture but it
says that uh he opened up and uh that
you know the dogs were already beginning
to work on him at the time when Christ
was being taken out of the city showing
the judgment
that's why Jesus said it would have been
better for him not to have been born
than to betray the Son of God so he hung
himself the Rope broke and he fell
okay next holiday we have is uh Tony
listening in Fiji Tony welcome to the
program
yep hey Tony thank you for calling
hello yes Rula
can you hear me I can hear you you hear
us oh thank you
uh thank you sorry I I just said uh a
question regarding uh Matthew 27
1927 verse 52 and verse 53. uh it talks
about uh when Jesus died on the cross
many bodies of the sins it's left arose
and then in verse 53 and came out of the
Greece after his resurrection
and ran into the holy city appeared unto
me so I'm just wondering is this two
separate resurrections so we did this
the same one
uh well when the the graves opened uh
during the earthquake and it says many
of the bodies of the Saints who had
fallen asleep were raised and coming out
of the graves after his resurrection so
it almost sounds like that the
earthquake opened the graves and after
Christ Rose they came out of the graves
and went into the holy city and appeared
to many
I don't think they Rose and laid in
their graves until Sunday morning
what's your yeah I agree I mean it could
be two ways the one is that they came
into the city
um after they were Resurrected and then
of course the the graves broke open at
the time of Christ's death so maybe
their graves broke open they were
resurrected at that point but didn't
appear until after Christ rose from the
dead or they could have been dead until
after Christ rose from the dead and then
they were resurrected but it's the same
group that came described yeah I always
thought it was the resurrection of
Christ that really gave them power to
rise he's the first yeah first
resurrection so
um and then they ascended to heaven with
Jesus as the first fruits but yeah
wonderful uh wonderful example of and we
don't know who was in that group it says
many of the Saints it's not all of them
now we know David wasn't in that group
yeah because it says in Acts chapter 1
it says he's dead and buried his grave
is still with us right
but maybe Elisha we don't know we can
only speculate Elisha yeah
all right hey thanks so much do we have
time for half a question no it doesn't
look like it
listening friends let us just remind you
someone mentioned during one of the uh
questions they said we just picked up
the new amazing facts devotional on
Revelation amazing facts spent uh two
years writing a verse by verse
devotional it goes through every verse
in the Book of Revelation there's 404
verses we divided those 404 verses among
the 365 days in a year and it is a daily
devotional that will take you through
the entire Book of Revelation explaining
the passages and also devotional
thoughts I think you'll find really
encouraging and now is a great time to
pick one of those up so when January
comes you can say I'm going to spend
this next year reading through the Book
of Revelation especially when you
consider where we are in history right
now you'll be blessed by that I think
they can just go to
afbookstore.com and they'll find more
information on how they can order one of
those books it's the amazing facts
Revelation devotional and also also want
to remind you that with this program
we've got like two big pools of
listeners we have some listening via
satellite and some who are listening via
regular land-based radio stations they
are on different time clocks so we're
going to say farewell in a few moments
to our friends who are listening on
satellite but don't go away those of you
who are on all the other stations
because we're going to do rapid fire
Bible questions and you can send in your
Bible questions for the time just send
them into balquestions at
amazingfacts.org
we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
[Music]
Hello friends welcome back as mentioned
just a little while ago we're going to
take some of your questions that you've
emailed to us you can email again at b a
l questions at
amazingfacts.org all right Pastor back
first question should you leave an
inheritance for your kids if they are
not Christians
yes
I didn't say how much that would depend
on how much you have and how much they
can handle but uh you know while you
don't want you know if your kids are
have gone away from the faith and you're
thinking well leaving money to my kids
that are unbelievers isn't that like
leaving it into the hands of the enemy
you know you want to show your kids that
you do love them
and does God also bless does he send
rain on the just and the unjust
so I think you need to leave them
something and show them you love them
and but of course you want to make the
work of God and the message of God a
priority your believing kids will
understand that but also leave something
for them that's I think that's a good
policy to follow and I think it's
supported by Proverbs as well okay next
question on behalf since Jesus fasted
for 40 days do we still need to fast yes
because even after Jesus fasted we don't
need to fast 40 days but Christ in The
Sermon on the Mount he said when you
fast he didn't say if you fast and then
he said that once the bridegroom is
taken away then the friends of the
bridegroom will fast so Paul talks about
fasting all through the New Testament
it's uh something that's a healthy and a
good practice to occasionally fast as
believers okay we have a question from
Dora in Maryland she says why do most
Christians say that the Ten Commandments
are not really part of the New Covenant
and don't have to be kept
they misunderstand where Paul says that
we are not under the law they think oh
we're not under the Ten Commandments
anymore and they assume that means we
don't have to keep them but if you
follow that to its ultimate conclusion
it's absurd to say ah I'm a Christian I
can now kill I can lie I can commit
adultery I can steal I can use God's
name in vain obviously that's absurd
when it says you're not under the law it
means Believers are no longer under the
penalty of the law the penalty for sin
is death Jesus saves us from the death
penalty by his grace then we want to
obey God's law because we love him if
we're not keeping the law Jesus said we
don't know him if any man says I know
him and keeps not his Commandments he's
a liar and the truth is not in him
that's what the Apostle John says so
when we are saved by grace we want to
obey God's law out of love Jesus said if
you love me keep my Commandments not
being under the law simply means by
Grace We're saved from the penalty of
the law not the law itself
hey thank you so much friends for
listening to Bible answers live and tell
your friends about the program to find
out more about amazing facts go to the
website amazingfacts.org
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]